i do think that there's everything that
we're seeing i think it is having an
impact on regular people check out the
story
bill maher on crowds hunger i'm sorry
bill maher on crowds hunger for mocking
wokeness quote for the first time i am
playing to a mixed audience
bill maher dings democrats for
leadership since trump left office i
would have liked a little more
competence
bill maher is not the the most you know
like
fallen line kind of guy he's always been
you know i'll say what i feel like
saying but when bill maher
all of a sudden is now getting a mixed
audience
i mean regular people are saying enough
so this is i i think the guy should have
taken the red pill a long time ago it
seems like he purposefully ignores these
stories and i do think that i i'm
willing to bet that bill maher deep down
inside knows how bad it is how screwed
the establishment and the democrats are
but he has to be careful because his
audience is all liberals i mean look at
snl they have so much material to work
with they have so many controversies
they have so many hiccups they have so
many just absolute goofball insane
moments and then they go light on joe
biden compare how they treated donald
trump compare how the media treated
donald trump i mean when donald trump
was in office every covet the death was
responsibly mainly because of donald
trump's policies the numbers are going
up biden's not being held to
responsibility it's also who they work
for right i mean you take more at hbo
the power is that being hbo or as far
left as you can be he doesn't the guy's
making a good salary you know it's
similar to when people say well you know
if there are good agents at the fbi or
there are good agents at atf speak up
yeah easier said than done when you're
making that kind of salary living check
to check and you've got a family to
support not that easy to blow up your
career with a guy like mar you blow up
your brand you blow up your influence
you blow up your salary i'm not saying
you shouldn't do it i mean thank god
he's not colbert and the vaccine dancer
creepy and freaking weird and freaky
but
you know you got to keep your audience
to an extent so how far can you push
yeah but i think the the real issue is
bill maher lost his audience a long time
he may have yeah i mean he he's retained
his viewership i think it's like 800
thousand 900 000 you know viewers per
episode yeah relative to most other late
night it's relative
for him it's it's yeah and for him i'll
say this i stopped watching a long time
ago
because yeah i mean you look at when he
came out against the covington kids yeah
it was a week after the story had
already been fact checked and then he
came out wrong and i'm like dude do you
have google like i can't watch this
stuff and so maybe now he's finally
realizing oh those people who used to
watch me i used to watch bill maher all
the time since i was like a teenager
and now i'm older and i'm like i can't
watch the guy he doesn't he doesn't even
read the news he probably has somebody
read the news form and tell him what to
say and they don't even fact-check
anything then he comes out and has mark
mangled opinions that don't make sense
but he's now starting to realize what's
going on you mentioned something earlier
we're talking about joe biden's approval
rating you said on the three metrics
which is i think money safety and family
overarching so there's there's there are
these um
i think those are maybe not specifically
that you know uh those three things but
similarly
they say that if people don't have
security shelter or food
they they revolt
and so when you look at the arab spring
people were saying food prices were
going up and so people were backed into
a corner
people who are fat and happy don't
revolt ever but when the shelves are
running dry
the shipping containers are backed up in
california and fauci goes on tv and says
no christmas
then people are going to be like my head
is going to explode and then you see the
parents show up that's how it starts you
know we had bannon on the show shout out
to ben for being right so the parents
are going to revolt and they find out
what's happening with their kids the
government reacts merrick garland
regular people this is why bill maher is
actually playing to a mixed audience
because regular people who are supposed
to be as honest all the time it's not
mixed this is the same people who used
to watch him they just have been paying
attention and he hasn't i think regular
people are on the verge of just snapping
off but you know what but most most
hosts are lazy i mean i'm gonna say
something about my industry your
industry we know this right i enjoyed
the research but most hosts
are pretty
most but a good portion are lazy they
come in they sit down they hope the
prompter is already filled out by their
producers it's been populated they get
the stories they get some clippings they
go through the motions they even when
they're supposed to be opinion
commentators won't name any names but
they're lazy as sin and and with that
laziness comes terrible content a lack
of critical thought a lack of critical
research and it happens on both sides
and unfortunately it's happening more on
the right and we're the ones who really
need to be
doing this i was here with you guys for
a few hours you guys were researching
intensively i used to do that on my show
i could tell you having been on radio
two major networks haven't been on tv
that's not the norm
sadly that's an exception these days
yeah there's a lack of passion there's a
lot of actors and there's a lot of
people who abuse substances in the media
business more than you would never be
surprised to know
a lot of them are are using substances
pills in ways that you'd be absolutely
shocked to find out about but they just
rely on their producers these producers
cycle through right oftentimes you find
these producers are in their early
twenties zero life experience they don't
know the back story on the story they're
reading the history of it who the
players are what a player in the biden
administration might have done
nefariously in the obama administration
that that's right deep research that
understanding of the content the
historical understanding just isn't
there well a good example is when we had
vosh on the show and i was talking about
you know to me it was it's funny that to
see these these leftists supporting joe
biden because we were literally
protesting him during occupy wall street
like he was the vice president he was
the partly you know uh he was a large
portion of what people were angry with
the bank balance all this stuff was
under under under the obama
administration and he went i was like i
don't know 10 years old i don't remember
that yeah and i was like oh no and i
don't i don't mean to disrespect by that
he literally wasn't politically active
or old enough to understand what what's
happening during occupy wall street
and so you know i think people need to
realize this
when when you wonder why the leftward
shift happened it's because young people
don't know anything about politics and
the right didn't do a good enough job
teaching young people
so what happens is the old school right
has effectively been just they're just
gone they're older folks and now you
have this millennial right which is
fairly moderate yeah so the wheel is is
shifting then you get these people like
you know jack dorsey and others and i'll
give a shout out to jack dorsey for
shouting out you know rothbard and i you
know things like that that surprised me
yeah that was surprising but do you get
the people working these millennial
leftists at big tech and they they
infiltrate cultural institutions they
take over and then all of a sudden
anyone who is you know further right
than moderate is is excised but i think
you know with the mar stuff i bring it
up because i think it's a good example
of
regular people reaching their wits end
they're waking up
but i don't want to be too optimistic
you know maybe there will be a big red
wave
maybe
people just don't care i think the
numbers show there will be i met with a
couple i had lunch today excuse me with
a couple of uh pretty astute political
strategies one pretty well known on our
side on the america first side and
they're encouraged
by the numbers they're encouraged by
what they see in 22.
so i think we do see a red wave but
going back to your point about the
culture we are
so far behind i mean we are
i don't know how we catch up and part of
the problem is we don't even understand
so many on the right don't even
understand what
taking back the culture means i have
these debates and even when i was on air
and off air and on twitter
and they'll say to me but we have dinesh
now look i think dinesh is a great guy i
love the guys i know personally
but that's not what we mean you can't
say we have dinesh when they have
hollywood and they have the music
industry and they've got the television
industry and they've got every producer
and they've got their line of succession
at the journalism schools ready to take
over or more those millennials you talk
about him who are even more left-wing
they've got their generational lines of
succession in place for two generations
and we're talking about documentaries i
mean we are
foundationally so far behind i don't
know how we do you got to build
technology that allows people to take it
back for themselves individually
is is the way to go technology culture
comes downstream from the technology of
the day and then downstream from that
you start to see politics created who
controls silicon valley though well a
lot of very strange weird rich people
right now the idea is no one controls it
it's a neutral ability for everyone so
so that's one of the things that we're
working on with the open network
foundation some of the work that ian's
been spearheading is you know open
source social media technology so that
people can't be banned but that's just
the machine like you're talking about
building an iron man suit someone's got
to pilot it so how do you get to the
point where the right and i don't mean
like the political right i mean like the
culture war right whatever it really
means the the pro-freedom people let's
say that yeah the pro-liberty individual
liberty the pro-america america first
how do you get those people to start
building culture well i'll put it this
way
you've got to start doing it and you've
got to go faster then they're doing it
that being said when you look at colbert
doing the vaccine shuffle or whatever
i'm not all that worried you know i i
think look we this is what we're doing
at timcast.com when you guys become a
member we've got the cast castle vlog
which was the first show we launched of
course we have this show we have like i
do my show in this show this is overt
discussion about political issues it's
in your face it's super liminal but then
we have the cass castle vlog where we
have like the dogs running around we get
the chickens you know they're funny and
they make funny noises and then we have
like jumping over the tesla on a bmx and
we have skating and we go to the you
know the river and we go to the
technology stores we go buy a bunch of
weird rocks that is just fun random
interesting stuff but that's culture
that's culture that's called and so the
goal is now we just launched tales from
the inverted world with shane cashman
hosting it's mystery paranormal ghosts
cryptids true crime and the goal is
produce good cultural content and have
your values translate out through it so
when we start doing
we're working on a new pop culture show
when we start doing that it's going to
be talking about a lot of general pop
culture stuff it's not going to be
political but of course you're going to
hear these opinions like don't ruin
james bond and it's going to be very you
know defensive of good content so it's
going to be critical of hollywood and
that's the kind of thing where you
create a space for regular people who
share your values to grow and flourish
and for the kids to find a space where
they can get good values and good ideas
and share them thanks for checking out
this clip from the tim cast irl podcast
if you want to see the full show come
back to this channel
youtube.com tim cast irl monday through
friday at 8pm where you can leave
comments and super chat and we actually
will read your comments on the show
don't forget to like share subscribe and
if you want exclusive members only
content segments you can't get anywhere
else go to timcast.com become a member
and we even have full bonus episodes
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time
you